ja es ist erst mal richtig dass wir über
eine russland krise sprechen und nicht
zuallererst nur über die ukraine krise
denn russland ist der aggressor das muss
man hier auch noch mal unterstreichen
und wir müssen für uns jetzt klar machen
welche folgen kann dieser weiter
anschwellende konflikt haben unsere
polnischen nachbarn rechnen derzeit
damit dass ungefähr eine millionen
migranten aus der ukraine nach polen
kommen könnten im ernstfall
und sie sind darauf vorbereitet sie
haben mit einem hilfsprogramm für die
ukraine derzeit vorkehrungen dafür
getroffen
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen vorzubereiten
sie reden darüber wie man arbeitsvisa
vereinfachen kann für die ukraine und
ich finde es ist jetzt an der höchste
zeit dass auch die bundesregierung für
den ernstfall vorbereitungen trifft ganz
klar wir wollen keinen krieg das wort
reden wir wollen die humanitäre
katastrophe in der ukraine vermeiden
aber wir müssen uns schon jetzt darauf
vorbereiten dass der gebetsmühlenartige
satz 2015 dürfe sich nicht wiederholen
die migrationspolitische auch in diesem
zusammenhang gilt wir dürfen nicht
unvorbereitet sein sondern die
innenministerin ist in der pflicht
zusammen mit ihren europäischen nachbarn
jetzt darüber zu reden wie wir auch eine
humanitäre katastrophe beantworten
könnten und dazu gehört ist das auch das
themenfeld der migrationspolitik noch
mehr in den blick fällt kommt das sehe
ich im moment bei der ampel in keiner
weise
das ist in keiner weise würden machst du
das fest wenn sie fehler hat sich dazu
geäußert hat gesagt sie ist wachsam sie
sieht dass man ist auch im austausch mit
polen was sind die konkreten forderungen
als wo sie die punkte das problem ist
glaube ich auf dem kündigt das ist jedem
klar das ist zu einer katastrophe kommen
könnte vor allem wenn der ernstfall
eintritt denen wir uns alle ausmalen
wollen aber was genau sind die konkreten
forderung also ich sehe das ganz
praktisch ich war dieser tage in meinem
wahlkreis in mecklenburg vorpommern
unterwegs und wenn ich mich dann
unterhalte mit den landräten wenn ich
mich mit denen unterhalten die eine
solche kommunale krise dann ja auch vor
ort schultern müssten
migrationspolitische da ist nichts
vorbereitet und ich habe die große sorge
und das ist auch etwas was viele vor ort
im moment spüren wiederholt sich so
etwas wie man es 2015 erlebt hat ich
kommentiere da seien wenig gibt es dann
den anruf jetzt in 24 stunden müsst ihr
euch um das thema der migration kümmern
das kann nicht richtig sein und vor
allem müssen wir glaube ich auch darüber
reden wie wir jetzt diese situation und
auch den migrationsdruck aus der ukraine
so auflösen dass es nicht allein zu
lasten der ukraine geht denn wir sehen
dass jeder flieger aus kiew in richtung
europa im moment komplett voll ist das
liegt daran weil alle dies können dieses
land verlassen wollen und das kann nicht
in unserem interesse sein und ich habe
von der ampel da nichts gesehen von der
bundesministerin habe ich zuletzt gehört
dass über eine koalition der willigen
zur aufnahme der flüchtlinge aus afrika
diskutiert die frage wie viele willige
dabei waren hatte sich schnell
beantwortet und sie müsste den
schwerpunkt jetzt auf zivilschutz legen
sie müsste den schwerpunkt jetzt auf
migrationsbewegungen ausrichtung der
ukraine liegen und da hat sie bisher gar
nichts vorbereitet aber im parlament
redet ja eh keiner mit uns olaf scholz
mal große dienstreisen im parlament
erklärt er sich nicht um die
innenministerin auch nicht also mehr ein
bezug auf der länder oder das findet im
moment überhaupt gar nicht statt den
eindruck habe ich und ich glaube an
vielen stellen ist es so dass wir jetzt
natürlich auf den best case einfach nur
hoffen wir hoffen darauf dass sich
dieser konflikt jetzt militärisch
entspannt und das ist natürlich auch
unser interesse wir haben ja kein
interesse an neuen migrationswellen und
wir haben auch kein interesse daran
jetzt dann in großen brain brain
auszulösen in richtung der ukraine aber
ich glaube zur wahrheit gehört schon
dass wir darüber noch viel viel klarer
reden müssen und dann gibt's die großen
diskussionen über bewohner und anderes
mehr mit den ländern darüber diese frage
redet keiner und wenn ich sehe wie
beschwerlich das auch alles war wenn man
es vor ort erlebt hat in folge von 2015
erstaufnahmeeinrichtung und co da glaube
ich müssen wir beim thema lessons
learned noch mal ein ganzes stück weit
besser werden weil wir die negative
erfahrungen die man in solchen situation
machen kann ja an vielen stellen schon
gemacht haben und nun hat man am
afghanistan-konflikt gesehen dass gerade
der militärischen rückzug des westens
der migrationsbewegung in gang gesetzt
hat das heißt dass das nicht als natur
geschehen sich ein von raab spielt und
wir dann mit den folgen konfrontiert
sind sondern dass man doch immer
unmittelbare auch wirkt wie unser
verhalten und unsere militärische und
strategische positionierung in diesen
konflikten auch auswirkungen hat auf
migration bewegung müsste das nicht auch
jetzt ein teil auch der politischen
diskussionen wollen das ist ohne frage
so und deswegen bin ich auch sozusagen
diskussionen von 5 noch einmal
aufzugreifen zu verlängern auch der
auffassung dass wir ganz klar jetzt auch
sagen können wir treten da jetzt nicht
die militärischen rollback kann ich mein
ich habe das mit bundeswehrsoldaten aus
mecklenburg vorpommern die jetzt in
litauen gerade im rahmen der nato
operation unterwegs sind sehe ich das ja
sehr sehr klar als die vor zwei jahren
das erst einmal darüber geredet haben
das dann das einsatzkontingent ansteht
und selbst als sie glück haben dafür da
sah das noch ganz anders aus als jetzt
ist es eine reale konfliktsituation und
so bitter das alles ist ich glaube wir
müssen da auch die präsenz
aufrechterhalten denn in dem moment wenn
wir als westen sagen soll putin da tun
was er tun will und wir schauen einfach
zu dann werden die menschen in der
ukraine mit den füßen abstimmen und
darüber entscheiden dass jeder der sich
in irgendeiner form aus diesem land
bewegen kann sich daraus bewegt und das
problem ist natürlich wir haben jetzt im
moment ja auch aufenthaltsrechtlichen
erhebliches problem denn faktisch bild
so im völkerrecht der vorrang sozusagen
der binnenflüchtlinge das heißt die
ukraine die jetzt sagen uns droht der
konflikt die haben hier gar nicht ohne
weiteres ein bleiberecht eine
dreimonatige perspektive und ich will
nicht dass jetzt sich alle auf den weg
machen nach europa und wir dann in
einigen monaten dastehen mit einem
problem wo wir wissen ja auch jetzt sind
die menschen zwar hier aber wir haben
für die aufenthaltsrechtliche gar keine
perspektive das müsste man vorher
überlegen das machen die polen richtig
das ist ein gutes stichwort die präsenz
vor ort wir haben ja auch bei uns haben
unseren chef report chefredakteur
stellvertretenden chefredakteur vor ort
aber für mich ist er immer noch in
erster linie ein ganz großartiger
reporter der ist uns jetzt zu bescheißen
wir möchten natürlich von paul wissen
wie die lage vor ort ist auch mit blick
natürlich auf die menschen mit wieviel
menschen kann deutschland denn rechnen
du hast philips thema gerade mit gehört
poul wie ist die lage was würdest du
schon entgegnen noch einmal verbinden
weil ich deine frage auf den ohren nicht
verstanden hatte nina eins kann ich
sagen ich bin sehr geschockt von eurer
diskussion die dort gerade geführt wird
auf der einen seite höre ich wie ihr
über die fehler die sie in den 90er
jahren gegeben hätte mit vladimir putin
und wie man mit ihm hätte umgehen müssen
sprechen auf der anderen seite spricht
er über die zukunft und die sagt ja was
machen wir nun mit den flüchtlingen ich
kann euch sagen
hinaus zu keine die hier sind freunde
von mir die nicht wissen was morgen
mit ihren freunden mit ihrer frau und
ihren kindern ist es ist eine situation
für die ukraine
komplett alleingelassenen ist von dieser
welt und
ich muss sagen ich bin schon wirklich
geschockt darüber wenn ich höre wie
roger köppel sagt ja wir wollen nicht in
diesen krieg natürlich wollen wir nicht
in diesen krieg aber wer denkt denn die
menschen hier vor ort an die ukraine
hier hinter mir das ist der don was das
ist die ost ukraine und in wenigen
stunden könnten hier russische soldaten
vor der tür stehen und dann die tür
klopfen mich festnehmen
mich würden sie wieder frei lassen aber
meine freunde festnehmen weil sie zu pro
ukrainisch sind weil sie aus der sicht
des westens aus der sicht russlands
sozusagen ja das falsche getan haben
hier wird über kill ist über todeslisten
gesprochen über
menschen die dann festgenommen werden im
lager gesteckt werden das ist die
realität hier das ist das was gerade
passiert in der ukraine und
ich finde bedenken viel zu wenig daran
dass wie es den menschen hier geht ich
habe leider gerade sozusagen meine
leistung hier verloren versuche ich
jetzt noch mal zu erreichen hier direkt
damit die mir noch eine frage stellen
könnte ich höre ich momentan nicht auf
die mauer
gerade des autors paul ronzheimer sagt
ist es ja umso wichtiger sich die frage
zu stellen warum sind wir überhaupt in
so eine situation gekommen punkte als
und was können wir machen um diese
situation zu bereinigen wenn die frage
ist ja was der viele beamte wurde gesagt
hat wir sprechen jetzt schon von
flüchtlingen und ich sage wie kommen
flüchtlinge verhindern wie kann man das
leid verhindern ja indem man den
konflikt eskaliert und die amerikaner
hat meines erachtens nicht das interesse
diesen konflikt jetzt absolut zu
diskutieren aber wir in europa und ich
bin auch schweizer nach in europa wir
haben ein interesse daran diesen diesen
konflikt zu deeskalieren und das was
putin will da wir ja auch keinen krieg
führen mit 150000 truppen kannst du
nicht einen riesigen stadt erhob und ist
keine invasionsarmee aber man muss immer
aufpassen was sie machen und der putin
ist natürlich ein ganz abgefeimte
strattera bleiben hat ja auch schon
verneinen version zb gesprochen also
nicht gut sie haben sie haben die
polnischen geheimdienst haben immer mal
wieder ein anderes dort umgebracht oder
morgen ja nicht falsch aber der punkt
ist jetzt aber der punkt ist durch dr
was wollen die russen was ist das
interesse der russen wir müssen hier
über die interessen sprechen und die
russen möchte nicht dass die kleine
weißrussland diese sicherheits gehörten
in die nato es fehle hineingezogen wird
ein spielball wird und wenn der westen
sich dazu durchringen könnte mit putin
an einem tisch zu sitzen ist auch eine
beschreibung gekommen als jede
eskalation verhindert putin will die
grenzen der länder auf dem europäischen
kontinent verschieden das ist seine
interessenlage wenn wir darüber reden
was putin will weißrussland will dann
muss es doch ganz klar sein denen geht
es doch nicht nur irgendwie um eine
pufferzone
demilitarisierung putin will zurück zu
den vorstellungen russlands als großes
sowjetisches reich r bilder seine
einflusssphären erweitern und machen wir
uns nichts vor sein interesse ist und
das zeigt sich doch sehr deutlich wenn
man diese rede hört wie die ukraine
spricht er will nicht nur irgendwie die
ukraine dem militarisieren sondern er
spricht er das existenzrecht ab er will
sie in russischem hoheitsgebiet
hineinbringen und das kann ich in
unserem interesse sein so kann man nicht
mit internationalen rechnung die paul
ist jetzt wieder da die leighton müsste
widerstehen wir hoffen es auf jeden fall
ist es ja immer palast uns jetzt wieder
werden ich höre ich wieder ich hoffe ihr
habt das gehört was ich gerade gesagt
habe ich hatte euch nur auf den ohren
nicht nur deswegen die telefonleitung
bestimmen wir haben alles er gehört was
du gesagt hast hast du uns daher nach
gott wirklich noch etwas ja antworten
sonst hätte findet am tor auch noch eine
frage an dich in die ukraine kenne ja
also erstmal herzliche grüße und danke
auch fürs fürs live berichterstattung
ich glaube das ist ganz wichtig dass man
in der tat den blick jetzt darauf wirft
wie es die situation vor ort und die
menschen fragen sich in der tat nicht
wie ein historiker seminar woran liegt
deswegen was ist die erwartung
eigentlich der menschen vor ort ich habe
jetzt so ein bisschen das thema
migration zwar mitgebracht für den worst
case aber ich glaube die allermeisten
wollen doch in der ukraine bleiben was
wünscht man sich da was es die botschaft
aus der ost ukraine die wir mitnehmen
sollen ins parlament
man wünscht sich eines frieden
und man weiß hier in der ost ukraine
woran das liegt dass es keinen frieden
gibt ich war heute an der front in einem
dorf bin dann als es beschuss gab
zusammen mit einer alten frau müller
nach unten gegangen in diesen keller
und ich habe sie gefragt was glaubst du
woran liegt das was ist mit diesem
konflikt und sie hat gesagt putin macht
gerade einen großen fehler meine kinder
sind alle in russland ich habe kein
problem mit russland ich verstehe nicht
warum gesagt wird das ist von der
ukraine angeblich eine russland
freundlichkeit gebe und gleichzeitig
haben die leute den glauben völlig
verloren dass die deutsche politik die
europäische politik die us-politik
irgendetwas tun könnte um irgendjemanden
zu retten der in dieser nacht in den
nächsten stunden morgen übermorgen hier
angegriffen wird hier wo ich gerade
stehe daher glaubt niemand sanktionen
die hat putin eingepreist all das was
dort gerade erklärt wird es lächerlich
dass das ist längst gewählt worden all
die sanktionen sind viel zu schwach die
jetzt gerade passiert sind auch was
oligarchen angeht was diejenigen angeht
die mit putin zu tun haben ich glaube
deutschland hat nicht verstanden was
hier gerade passiert putin hat dieses
land umzingelt mit all den truppen die
er dort stehen hat hunderttausende und
all das was wir hören ich habe gerade
mit dem auto und mit dem präsidenten
selensky sprechen können alle anzeichen
deuten darauf hin dass der angriff gegen
die ukraine und nicht in
anführungszeichen nur und das ist ja
auch schon absurd gegen die ost und
keine sondern dass ein großer angriff in
den nächsten 48 stunden passieren wird
keiner glaubt daran dass der westen
irgendetwas tut und alle
sind verzweifelt hier
bei vielen herzlichen dank für deine
berichte wir werden auch morgen die der
zu dir in die ukraine scheint neben nach
8 und dranbleiben dankeschön für den
einsatz vor ort